Mientras estaba haciendo
mi pequeño análisis
para darme cuenta si el plan básico
o el plan de prueba es el que más me conviene
e hicimos un análisis
para determinar el número de sesiones
donde el costo del plan de prueba es
igual al costo del plan básico.
Hice estos cálculos
donde obtuve que eran 5 sesiones,
no me di cuenta pero el encargado del estudio
de Súper Yoga me estaba viendo y me dijo,
"bien Sal, eso está muy bien
lo que hiciste, maravilloso,"
según entiendo hay un número de sesiones
donde "12s" es exactamente igual a 20 más "8s"
donde obtenemos exactamente el mismo costo,
donde 20 más 8 por "s" es igual a 12 por "s",
otra manera de ver esto
es que la "c" que obtienes con 20 más "8s"
coincide con la "c"
que obtienes con "12s".
Las igualamos, encontramos "s"
para posteriormente encontrar el costo,
pero el encargado me dice,
"yo tengo otra manera de hacerlo
y quiero ver si obtenemos la misma respuesta".
Así es que,
según su manera de verlo,
me dice "fíjate en esto,
sabemos que el costo del plan básico...
sabemos que el costo del plan básico es igual a 20 dólares, 20 dólares por sesión,
bueno no, de hecho son 20 dólares de
adelanto que se tienen que dar, más...
más 8 dólares por cada sesión...
más "8s"."
Eso es lo que sabemos
y lo que queremos averiguar es
¿cuál es el número de sesiones donde
obtenemos el mismo costo
tomando el plan básico
o tomando el plan de prueba?
Y me dijo, "tengo una idea para transformar esta ecuación en una ecuación de una sola variable",
actualmente es una ecuación que nos da
el costo dependiendo del número de sesiones,
pero él tenía o por lo menos pensaba que tenía
una manera para eliminar la "c" de la ecuación.
Me dijo, "lo que voy a hacer es restar
la "c" del lado izquierdo"
me dijo entonces que simplemente...
simplemente iba a restarles "c" del lado izquierdo,
a lo cual repliqué, "espera, espera un momento,
no puedes restar "c",
no puedes hacer algo que solo afecte una lado
de la ecuación, pues se perdería la igualdad"
y me dijo,
"no, no, no, no te preocupes,
la ecuación no se va a alterar
pues voy a hacer lo mismo
del lado derecho de la ecuación"
y entonces yo le dije,
"eso no tiene ningún caso,
pues ahora va a aparecer la "c"
del lado derecho de la ecuación,
vas a terminar con
20 más "8s" menos "c",
así es que no vas a deshacerte de la "c",
aún vas a tener dos incógnitas"
y me dijo, "no, no, no Sal, no has entendido,
voy a restar "c" del lado izquierdo,
pero sabemos que estamos buscando una "s",
de tal manera que "12s" nos da el mismo costo "c",
este costo ya sea que use el plan básico
o use el plan de prueba,
va a ser exactamente el mismo,
así es que cualquiera que sea el costo que obtenga,
ya sea por el plan básico o por el plan de prueba,
voy a restar ese costo del lado izquierdo,
de tal manera que se cancelen las "c",
mientras que del lado derecho
voy a restar el costo de "12s",
así es que lo que hizo fue restar "c" del lado izquierdo, cancelando así las "c" y del lado derecho restó "12s"...
"12s", así que me pregunto,
¿es esto que hizo algo válido?
Básicamente está restando esta ecuación de esta ecuación, está restando "c" dellado izquierdo,
mientras que del lado derecho,
está restando "12s", ¿es esto correcto?
Pensemos en esto.
Sabemos que si tenemos una ecuación y sumamos
o restamos algo del lado izquierdo,
tenemos que hacer exactamente
lo mismo del lado derecho.
Lo que él está haciendo es considerar
que sin importar que plan tomamos,
existe un número de sesiones
donde obtenemos el mismo costo.
Así es que restemos ese costo del lado izquierdo
y ese costo tiene que ser igual a "12s",
esto es lo que queremos que se cumpla,
sabemos que estas dos ecuaciones tienen
que ser verdad en este punto de coincidencia.
Me dijo, "mira, si estas dos son iguales
entonces restar "12s" de un lado,
es totalmente equivalente a restar "c" del otro lado,
así es que de hecho, esta es una operación válida."
Está restando lo mismo,
está restando "c" aquí y está restando "12s" aquí,
sabemos que es lo mismo pues estamos poniendo
esa restricción,  sabemos que "c" es igual...
queremos que "c" cumpla el mismo tiempo que
"c" igual a 20 más "8s" y que "c" sea igual a "12s",
como "c" tiene que ser igual a "12s" podemos
restar "c" de un lado y "12s" del otro lado.
Veamos adonde nos lleva esto.
Si restamos "c" de un lado
y restamos "12s" del otro lado,
desarrollemos entonces
estas operaciones.
¿Del lado izquierdo qué obtenemos?
"c" y "-c" se cancelan, "c" y "-c" nos da 0,
estos dos términos se cancelan
y acabamos con 0 del lado izquierdo.
¿Del lado derecho qué obtenemos?
20 queda como 20 y 8 de algo menos 12 de algo,
"8s" menos "12s" es igual a "-4s",
nos queda entonces 20 menos "4s".
Y observemos algo interesante, ahora tengo una sola ecuación con una sola incógnita, "s".
Debemos entonces
poder despejar de esa ecuación la "s",
¿y cómo lo hacemos?
Bien, necesitamos dejar la variable de un
lado y yo lo voy a hacer del lado izquierdo,
como bien sabes hay muchísimas maneras
de despejar una variable.
¿Qué puedo hacer entonces para tener las "s" del lado izquierdo y eliminarlas del lado derecho?
Así es que para eliminar las "s" del lado derecho,
si estoy restando "4s" aquí,
necesito sumar entonces "4s",
sumamos "4s".
Y de nueva cuenta no puedo hacer esto nada más del lado derecho, pues perderíamos la igualdad,
así es que tengo que hacerlo también
del lado izquierdo.
¿Y qué obtenemos ahora?
Bien, obtenemos 0 más "4s" del lado izquierdo,
es "4s" y del lado derecho obtenemos,
"-4s" y "4s" se cancelan,
estos términos se cancelan
y nos queda tan solo 20.
La ecuación es ahora "4s" es igual a 20.
Ahora, para despejar "s" dividimos entonces "4s" entre 4, cuando tenemos 4 de algo,
dividido entre 4,
nos queda ese algo,
así es que en el lado izquierdo
hemos despejado "s"
de nueva cuenta
para no afectar la ecuación,
también tenemos que dividir
entre 4 del lado derecho,
nos resulta entonces que "s" es igual a
20 entre 4 o "s" es igual a 5 sesiones.
Que es exactamente la respuesta
que habíamos obtenido antes
y podemos regresar entonces
a cualquiera de los planes
y ver que en ambos casos
el costo mensual va a ser 60 dólares.
Lo curioso del caso es que tanto el dependiente
del estudio Súper Yoga como yo,
llegamos a la misma respuesta
por distintos métodos.
Y debido a que lo que ambos hicimos
fue lógicamente consistente
y esto es lo maravilloso del álgebra,
obtuvimos la misma conclusión.
Mientras sigamos procedimientos
que tengan consistencia lógica,
siempre llegaremos a la respuesta exacta.